right here how are
[Music]
you now that our chair the chairman is
here we can
start I'm Jack Whitehead and for the
last three years I've been chairman of
the friends of the National Library of
Medicine and on behalf of the friends I
want to thank you for coming uh this
afternoon we're taking an exciting step
forward in the field of biotechnology
research late last year a new National
Center for biotechnology information was
established with the National Library of
Medicine today distinguished officials
from the Department of Health and Human
Services are here to announce the name
of the first director of that Center
biotechnology is perhaps today's most
important area of medical scientific
research a few years ago biotechnology
was rarely heard today the field is so
crowded it's becoming nearly impossible
to keep up with all the research and the
tremendous flow of data and information
being
produced American firms are now spending
uh some $2 billion a year on bio
technology research which is in addition
to the billions being spent by n
for-profit
Laboratories by the year 2000 it's
estimated there'll be A40 M billion doll
a year industry in this country
biotechnology research holds the key to
unlocking many of the secrets of who we
are how we get sick and how we heal it
can open doors to discovering new
treatments and new cures for some of the
estimated 4,000 diseases that afflict us
from cancer to colds from aging to
AIDS but research is so fastpaced today
we have trouble keeping up with it with
handling and coordinating the results of
research and making it quickly and
readily available to researchers and the
scientists who need it that's why this
Center for biotechnology information is
so important its mission is to develop
and manage information Handling Systems
to coordinate the flow of research
information on human molecule human
molecular biology biochemistry and
genetics it's a tremendous Challenge and
a tremendous need few people understand
this need more than chairman Claude
pepper he's the architect of legislation
creating this Center and has led many
battles for better
healthare it's with great honor I
introduce to you a true friend of ours
chairman Claude pepper to discuss this
important new addition to the library
chairman
P thank you very
much Mr chairman and the distinguished
the head of the Library of Medicine and
the biotechnological
center ladies and gentlemen I'm sorry to
be a little late
this is one of the most important
measures I believe that has been enacted
by the company it was a a recommendation
to me from the library of
medic which has done so much to
assimilate and to
distribute necessary and useful
information in the health
field as I understand that today a rural
physician in America could go to a
telephone on and call the American
Library of Medicine the general Library
of Medicine and get whatever information
that's on storage there in respect
to disease that he didn't know how to
diagnose but it has
limitations and the field of
biotechnology is expanding so rapidly
especially in research and respect to
the
genes where we deal with millions of
billions of little cells in the
body that the resources that we now have
are inadequate first to assimilate and
second properly to distribute the
necessary information in respect to bi
technology especially in the field of
the
genes I regard that is one of the most
productive and promising areas of
research in our nation
today they tell us that that the this
little thing that we call the the
DNA is the architect's plans for the
human
body and just as the building is the
reflection of the architect plans we are
the reflection of the state of those DNA
things and uh if some Gene gets out of
place or some other out of orbit or out
of function of
propriety it may cause all measure of
disease and difficulty in the human
body they ined that we may learn enough
in time for example the two cases that
have been given by the Library of
Medicine a lady from almost from her
youth has been
emaciated beset
by
deterioration in a body of constant
pneumonia
but uh with the hope that we have
someday they may be able to plant a
healthy Gene in the bone maror of that
lady she will immediately cease to be a
victim of pneumonia and
emaciation and become a normal healthy
human being another case they inv visit
this a young man with LMP
cancer but by inerting a healthy gene
into that
man's body they hope they may be able
immediately to arrest that
cancer just think
400,000 people a year one of them was my
beloved wife
mild are victims of that monster
cancer this may be the way we'll find
the cause and cure how that terrible
killer
and maybe others of similar
destructiveness to our
population but if I'm a
researcher and I want to know about a
particular area of research and what's
been done already in that field there's
nowhere now I can find that information
because there no facilities to acquire
it and to assimilate it and to distribut
it so what we have done by this bill is
to set up in the General Library of
Medicine new computer system that will
be adequate to accomplish this High
purpose to assimilate all the research
that's been going on however voluminous
it may be and to have that research
available to all those who need it and
want to use it in trying further to
develop the science of bi
technology so I regard this as one of
the Monumental achievements of the
Congress and the country and I think it
has immeasurable hope and incalculable
consequence for our future so I'm I'm
very proud that I've been the instrument
the initiative didn't come from me it
came from that great institution the
National Library of Medicine they told
me about it I thought it was a great
idea and I was proud to introduce and
try to secure the page of the bill so I
want to compliment the National Library
of Medicine and the chairman of it here
and uh Francis Humphrey Howard who's
been working with us on this matter all
of them who are involved in this
Enterprise I'm very grateful to have had
a part in it and I hope and pray that
it's going to realize the dreams that
many of us have cherished for a long
long time by being able to prolong the
lives and promote the health and
happiness of the human
beings we had a case down in Florida the
other day that that Disturbed me very
much a lady a widow with three
children went to our Jackson Memorial
Hospital 14
times tried to get an examination of her
breast but she suspected that maybe she
had the cancer coming she couldn't get
any attention or any
care the 14th time some assistant
finally examined her yes you do have
cancer but she died in 3
weeks that that's surely is not
America that might be some backward
country in the
world but surely surely that's not
America and I I do hope the
consciousness of our country is being
quickened to
realize how many people in America are
dying
unnecessarily how many are suffering
from poor health when they could have
better health how many have denied
happiness when they could enjoy life
better this may be the the open sesame
to a longer a healthier and a happier
life and God grant that it will be for
the American people and indirectly for
the people of the world so I'm proud to
have the honor to be associated in this
gigantic Enterprise with that great
Institution the National Institute of
Health and the National Library of
Medicine thank you very
much thank you chairman pepper I think
on behalf of the library or certainly
the friends of the library we all owe
you a great debt and uh we wouldn't be
here if it weren't for you I want to
acknowledge the presence of uh Dr James
wearden who is the director of the
National Institute P who uh to which the
library of medicine is part of wow
that's a great sentence and uh also
introduce to you Dr Donna Lindberg who
is the director of the National Library
of Medicine I'd like to ask him to say a
few words and introduce the new director
of the national Center for biotechnology
information who will then be available
for questions thank
you
Senator Pepper Dr wne gon Mr wead ladies
and gentlemen it's a pleasure to be with
you and Mr wead said a few words and
I'll stick to that the uh investigation
of the workings of the human hereditary
system is certainly the most exciting
scientific Enterprise of the century and
it's uh a proud thing for the National
Library of Medicine to to be the
information repository for the results
of that will come from that research
because I think they as Mr pepper
suggested will help us
all it is logical that it do it because
the he and the rest of Congress has
wisely uh put these results in the
public domain and it is our special to
very well because of the uh selection of
David Litman as the new director and his
agreement to serve in that capacity he's
a outstanding investigator in the field
to present to Dr lman and perhaps you'll
wish to ask him how he's going to
proceed they uh they they struck
me if there's any
questions is this Center going to
require B upgrading or improvement in
our current computer knowledge to get
the job done and how much is it going to
C
well let me stick with the first part
for now uh I I need more experience for
the second part later on but uh I think
that uh there's a number of kinds of
problems that we have to deal with some
are problems which in some ways don't
require new basic research they require
uh sort of a global view of what the
informatics problems are um coordinating
various efforts that already exist
because there's not been a center so far
some of the various efforts have kind of
gone in their own directions and we're
going to try to help maintain a central
Focus so that the various databases can
maintain uh communication with them with
each other um other problems however uh
will require I think real basic research
biological research uh new algorithms
new uh um new insights into what is the
language of DNA I mean we know how DNA
codes for proteins but when people talk
about um um if you have an amino acid
sequence what does that tell you about
the structure and function of their
protein I think that we can contribute
in that area by doing basic research and
sequent structur uh problems and so
forth uh uh
so when you talked about vast upgrading
I got the sense of Hardware problems
yeah I mean there's like a computer is
it going to be new hardware new software
is this technology out there is it
something you're going to have to uh
invent I I think that right now
[Music]
um the hardware is actually improving at
such an incredible rate that uh several
years ago people talked about gez we're
going to need special computers for
searching databases and so forth but
just in the time that I've been involved
in the field um we found that the
opposite has happened computers have
gotten the price performance in
computers has increased faster than the
databases have now with a new human
genome effort I think that's going to
change and we're going to see a
tremendous increase amount of
information and there will be the need
for new uh Hardware new computer
Technologies but one of the real focuses
in the center is a brain we are going to
try to bring to the Library of Medicine
um experts in a variety of areas uh and
achieve a critical mass of of uh of uh
brainware that we can focus on problems
and come up with with with Solutions
which don't necessarily mean you know
you know uh more computers uh but I do
think that uh with time there will be
need for for upgrading the kind of
facilities that are
available how do you plan to address the
issues of inflicting standards and and
software and the existing genome
databases in Europe for
example well that's a that is a problem
uh there are a few things that are
happening that I think will help to
change that one is that with the Human
Genome Project I think there's a a
realization by all the existing
databases that that things are going to
have to change that these are no longer
little private research projects but
that uh cooperation has to become the
rule and not the exception
um I think that uh uh Dr Watson who has
been um
uh obviously worrying about these
problems as well um is uh hoping to
develop a very close tie with the center
and I think that uh the combination of
the human genome office um and uh this
National biotech Center um uh at the
library will be able to instill a little
more respect for standards because NIH
to some extent will be speaking with
with one voice on some of these issues
um have you chosen an Advisory Board yet
and if so who's going to be on
it
uh if you want to make a
statement have you chosen an Advisory
Board yet and if so who's going to be on
it well um Dr weart uh might want to
answer the question because he arranged
a Consulting Group before the before Dr
Watson came there is a national genome
advisory Council committee committee and
uh it was decided by the group in Reston
and then subsequently by the committee
itself that that we would like to stay
with that body we'd like to establish a
subcommittee of that committee and be
advised by them and so that's the manner
in which we're working right at the
moment the members of that subcommittee
are uh botstein from jentech haime
caranel from Carnegie melon and uh
Pearson from DuPont they have the
ability to add additional members but at
the moment that is the group which will
be overlooking overseeing the uh the
information comp component of the Genome
Project
well M for I asked what's the Rel
essentially with this instrumentality be
an operation it is an operation it is an
operation we're at working we got 10
million how much you guys 8 million a
year 8li yeah eight out of 10 but that's
a plenty good start we're uh working
hard Miss for I asked about the
relationship of the Human Genome Project
with biotechnology and I suppose that
the latter term is the broader one since
it includes both uh industrial and plant
applications and Drug production and so
forth whereas the Human Genome Project
just wants to know the heredity of the
human being but in fact that is very
much informed by the knowledge from
lower forms and other animal forms so
that it would be perhaps the first
really big step in biotechnology would
be the human gene project Human Genome
Project
okay if there are no further questions I
think we'll adjourn to reception one
more I don't think uh Congress this
question answered as to when it's going
to be online and and two if I might ask
has anything like this been tried before
in terms of pooling ongoing research and
you have any doubts about the
willingness of scientists to share this
information at an early stage along line
a lot of questions there
um when uh Dr Lindberg said that we're
online it means that uh uh there are
people who are already at the library
who say they're part of the center and
we're already working on problems
currently we're recruiting people but
there are ongoing problems in terms of
integrating the database um uh
integrating physical map databases and
genetic databases and so forth um um I
think will be uh more operational in the
coming months but with respect to uh uh
uh are there models for this level of
cooperation that we're talking about um
[Music]
uh within the biological community I
don't think so because people have
talked about you know the the sort of uh
uh small uh uh scale projects that
biology has been so far and whereas the
Human Genome Project we're talking about
scaling up quite a bit um but I think
that the attitudes are changing rapidly
as people see the
advantages